The joe rogan experience.
But I just think, um, I
mean it's a fucked up thing.
I mean it's a weird thing to say,
but I really think we all collectively
as a species need to emphasize and learn
how to be nicer to each other.
Nobody teaches you that. It's rare.
They teach you in school, be nice when
you go to offices. There's, you know,
there's certain standards of behavior
that you're supposed to behave in,
but there's not like
an emphasis on kindness
and just being friendly.
And I think that that doesn't
diminish competition now.
Like you can be friendly and kind to
people that you're competing with as hard
as you can.
That was also a thing that you find at
Jujitsu guys who were just trying to kill
each other all the time or like really
close friends, really close and you know,
very competitive like, motherfucker, I'm
getting you tonight. No bitch not right.
You know, like that kind
of shit. But friendly.
Well because there's a safety,
because there's rules and in the workplace
the rules are much more nebulous and
what you do to get ahead kissing a boss,
his ass sabotaging a project.
Is that part of competitive
or is that over the line?
Whereas with Jujitsu you'll
get called on a foul.
Yeah. Sabotaging a project. God.
Imagine working with somebody and
they're sabotaging what you're trying to
accomplish.
Go to the boss and talking shit behind
your back about your project and what
you're trying to achieve.
That's one of the most soul sucking
things about jobs. The fakeness.
Yeah, the, the office banter.
Nonsense fakeness. I just
think as a, as a species,
just the human race,
especially us as Americans because
they're so God damn competitive,
kinda learn how to be nicer.
I think it starts with manners.
I think it starts with,
I mean as a parent manners,
they seem trivial,
but it creates the paradigm
for Nice just thank you.
Please hold a door,
don't eat till it like don't eat
until everybody's served their food.
They're all little signals to people that
you care about them and respect them.
And I think it spills over and it informs
your other actions when you have good
manners. Right. Look, people in the eye.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It'd be deployed.
And when people do that to you,
you get a good feeling.
You know, when you don't,
when someone holds up in the door
for you or someone says thank you,
like I said hi to some guy the other day
I was walking by him in the hallway of
a hotel. I go, how you doing man?
He just stared at me and
immediately I was like, why?
I was angry. Yeah. You know? Immediately
like, pardon my instinct was like,
fuck you man. Yeah. Then part me, it was
like that poor bastard. Right. You know?
And I went with that poor bastard.
That's his life.
I just said hi and just tried to be nice,
but he looked,
looked at me like I was almost like I
was weak in saying hi to him. Right.
You know?
I was raised to like,
like if I see somebody with bags,
I helped them and it makes
me feel fucking great.
It feels good to help people.
And I think I was raised,
and that's the thing about being raised
Catholic because I was raised very care
were you raised Catholic?
I was raised Catholic too.
First grade after first grade
we kind of abandoned it. Yeah.
But even up until then it's it,
it gives you a lot of um,
it's a life of service. It's very much
about helping people. It's very much she,
you know, he could say what you want
about the Catholics but you know,
they were in the trenches and a lot of
third world countries, nuns and you know,
they, they, they did a lot of good and
a, and I think that rubbed off on me.
My parents both always
did a lot of charity work.
I do a lot of charity work with
my kids and you know, that's,
that's going to stay with them.
I think we throw the baby out with the
bath water when it comes to religion and
even just rigid ideologies.
I think there's,
there's something about religion
that can absolutely help some people.
And there's aspects of it that are very
beneficial, having that code to live by.
You know, even if the, it's because of
the fucking spaghetti monster in the sky,
like whatever it is that you believe,
but if you really act that, that thing,
act like that thing is watching over you
and that there's codes and tenants that
you have to live by.
Like most of the tenants of Christianity,
if you look at them, if you really follow
Jesus's rule, which most people don't,
but if you really did, you'd be
doing a lot of great work. You know,
you'd be helping people,
you'd be treating each other as if
they were your brothers and sisters.
The neediest.
I mean,
that's who Jesus helped you helped the
beggars in the street and the prostitutes
and you know, that was some hardcore
shit he was doing back then. And um,
yeah, I think it's like, uh, the 10
commandments he can live by, I don't know,
eight of them.
Eight of them are pretty good to live by.
I'm still going to cover it. My
neighbor's wife Covet. She's fucking hot.
Do you know what that was about though?
It wasn't about that. What was it?
Your neighbors Wa she was possession.
She was covet,
like she was a a possession of the
neighbor. Yeah. Like she, he owned her,
right. Oh, that's right. And the
same thing stood for the commandment.
If you really read it says,
do not cover it.
Thy Neighbor's wife or thy neighbor slave.
Is it slave? Slave? It's a donkey.
I think it's donkey enslave. Really? Yup.
Wow. That's crazy. Yeah. Yeah. Don't,
don't try to steal their slave.
You could keep slaves.
Just felt want them from your neighbor.
It's just so obvious that what they were
talking about back then was all wrapped
around the way people thought
about things then. Yeah. You know,
but they knew even then,
even thousands of years ago,
they knew there's a right way to do things
and there's a wrong way to do things.
There's, when you pick up the
people's bags, you feel good.
Let's tell kids that was, teach people
that you pick up the bags, you feel good,
you hold the door open, you feel good. You
help someone, you feel good. Like, okay,
let's, this is obviously that
we all want to feel good, right?
How do we feel like there's moments in
my life where I feel terrible or I've
done something wrong or a fucked up
something or just failed and I just feel
terrible. And I always think when
I do have that feeling like, God,
I fucking hate this feeling.
Why can't I feel great?
Why can't I just feel awesome right
now? Well, because it didn't go well.
And this is like the psychic reminder.
This is that jolt of energy
that's letting you know like, hey,
you went on a wrong path. You
fucked up you, you'd tank this,
you crash that you did wrong. Like
you're supposed to feel like shit. Right.
So that you don't do it
again. Yeah. But conversely,
when something good happens,
when you help someone,
when someone can't get their bag in the
overhead because it's too heavy and you
help them and you hand it to them,
they smile at you and you smile at them.
You walk off the plane, you
feel good, you feel good.
You got to teach that to like, you have
to remember that and you have to go,
why do I feel so good? Oh, I felt so good
because it helped that lady, you know,
I felt so good because I said hi to
that guy and that guy say hi me back.
And we looked at each other
and go, you know, made some
niceties or whatever. Yeah.
And that's,
that's part of the joy of
life is those friendly,
fun, Nice interactions with people.
But when you got your shit in order,
it's easier to have those experiences
when you don't. My personal experience,
when I don't have my shit in order
and I've made mistakes and um,
I fucked something up. It's very
hard for me to enjoy anything. Yeah.
I just go through the motions.
I just, I feel like, Oh,
if I have something that I fucked up and
then, um, I have that terrible feeling,
but I have to hang out with my family
and my kids. I just ride it out.
I just have to ride it out. I tried
to be real friendly and real sweet,
but I don't feel good inside. I
feel terrible. And I go, well,
this is going to go away
with contemplation, with
understanding. It's going to,
this feelings going to go away, but
you got to ride it out. You know?
And I know I can ride it out because
I've read it out, wrote it out before.
But for some people, man, they
don't know what to do there, right?
Don't they don't know what that feeling
is. They feel like this is their life.
And then that feeling, if you don't
conquer it, you get comfortable with it.
You get used to it. You used to failing,
you get used to that terrible feeling.
And then he started pouring booze
on that terrible feeling, right?
Or pouring drugs or,
well, it also becomes like, uh,
I was in therapy and I remember
the therapist told me that you,
we all have a narrative of our lives
and you can choose that narrative.
It's that fucking simple.
That's basically what behavioral
therapy tells you is that it's all a
projection. Everything in your life
as a projection. You know, you say,
I have these attributes, I've
accomplished these things. Or you can say,
I lacked these things and I fucked up
these things and you can live your life.
What putting that energy out to people.
And it's as simple as just literally
sitting down and thinking about how you
want to see yourself and just keep,
keep reminding yourself of that and
you'll start to live. And I mean,
this sounds so fucking hokey and over
simplified, but it's real, but it's real.
You know, and I, and part of the thing,
the downside of religion is that I was
raised with a lot of shame and guilt.
And so those,
you're talking about where you fucked
up and you're feeling bad and you've got
to ride it out.
You throw shame on top of that and it
extends it and it makes it more profound.
And it's not just about your action and
how it might've affected other people.
It's about original sin. You know, heavy,
original sin should garden of Eden
where evil, you know, we're dirty.
We need to confess,
we need to be cleansed.
Throw all that on top of a simple mistake.
And again, it makes it complicated.
[inaudible]
yeah.